Dropping like flies (or at least as far as
many stories indicate), it seems as if well-bred
ladies in the 1800s struggled to maintain
consciousness when faced with even the slightest
emotional or physical shock.
Over the years there have been several theories
as to why this seemed to happen, from the
women’s garb to simply conforming to societal
expectations.
To begin with, throughout the 19th century
(among other times), ladies often wore corsets.
Worn around the torso, corsets were made of
a durable tightly woven fabric or leather,
fashioned with channels running throughout
them in which vertical ribs were inserted,
called boning because they were often made
with whale bone (although ivory and wood were
also used).
While the purpose of the corset changed over
time- sometimes meant to give a flat look,
sometimes meant to give extra curves via tightening,
it’s the latter fad, particularly in the
Victorian era, that many propose was the cause
of at least some fainting spells.
In this case, the entire device was held together,
and tightened (sometimes to extremes) by a
system of lacing.
The archetypical corset had its laces at the
back, and for the most fashionable ladies,
these had to be tightened by another.
Girls were started in corsets at a very young
age and, for them and ladies after childbirth,
waist training (to shrink the side of the
waist) via super tight lacing, was common.
child-corsetAs a result of this particular
version of corset fashion, over time, corset-wearers’
bodies changed: their ribs were displaced,
their lungs were squashed, some organs were
compressed against the spine and others were
shoved down into the lower abdomen.
In addition to making it hard to breathe,
hearts struggled to pump and, guts struggled
to digest what little food they could get
down.
As one Victorian lady is reported, “I had
only eaten two bites of my biscuit there was
no room beneath my corset for a third.”
Said the West Coast Times in August of 1884,
The evil consequences of tight lacing are
universally admitted.
Ladies, however, generally refuse to acknowledge
that tight lacing is at all common.
Each possessor of a small waist claims that
it is a gift of Nature, not a work of art,
and wears a corset, not for the purpose of
compressing her shape into a narrow circumference,
but merely as a comfortable, if not necessary
support.
This lead to the “great corset controversy”
of the 19th century.
Said one woman in a letter to the Boston Globe
in January of 1893,
I myself have never felt any ill effects from
nearly 30 years of the most severe tight lacing,
nor have I yet found any authentic case of
real harm being done by stays, even when laced
to the utmost degree of tightness, both day
and night.
People who write against the practice of tight
lacing are either those who have never been
laced and have never take the trouble to inquire
into the pros and cons of the subject, or
those who have, perhaps been once lace up
very tightly in badly made, ill-fitting stays
with the settled determination of finding
them most awful instruments of torture.
Those who have been systematically laced up
in proper stays from their childhood are the
only ones who are capable of forming a right
judgment on this subject and I hope you will
allow tight lacers the opportunity of defending
themselves against the enemies of trim little
waist.
On the other side of the argument, in an article
titled “The Slaves of Fashion,” published
in the Chicago Tribune in September of 1891,
it was noted,
It is difficult to imagine a slavery more
senseless, cruel or far-reaching in its injurious
consequences than that imposed by fashion
on civilized womanhood during the last generation.
… the tight lacing required by the wasp
waist has produced generations of invalids
and bequeathed to posterity suffering that
will not vanish for many decades.
… And in order to look stylish, thousands
of women wear dress waist so tight that no
free movement of the upper body is possible;
indeed in numbers of instances, ladies are
compelled to put their bonnets on before attempting
the painful ordeal of getting into glove-fitting
dress waists.
Whatever side of the tight laced argument
a particular woman was on, whether by their
suboptimal blood pressure, inability to breathe
properly, or low blood sugar, it’s thought
this may have been one potential cause for
Victorian ladies reportedly retreating to
their fainting rooms and swooning onto their
fainting couches.
Another fashion-based theory is that a well
dressed woman of this era wore an enormous
amount of clothing, and even in the summer,
such a lady had, in addition to the corset,
underwear, a bustle pad, a full skirt supported
by crinoline (read: horsehair) petticoats
(sometimes lined with steel hoops) and a bonnet.
Some may have fainted from overheating, while
others may have collapsed under the sheer
weight of their garments which would have
been more difficult to handle combined with
the other aforementioned cinching aspects.
(This could also be dangerous for other reasons.
For instance, the wife of famed poet Henry
Wadsworth Longfellow tragically died when
she accidentally dropped a burning match onto
her hoop skirt.
Her clothing burst into flames.
Even after the fire was smothered, it was
not an easy task to remove the cindered clothing.)
Another potential contributor sometimes pointed
to in trying to explain some of the swooning
could have been chronic poisoning.
During the 19th century, while people knew
that arsenic was poisonous, they didn’t
seem to know (or care) that environmental
exposure from its fumes could also have a
deleterious effect.
As such, and given its utility in certain
applications, it was widely used in the manufacture
of everything from fabrics to paints to the
paper in which food was wrapped; in fact,
by the end of the 1800s, 80% of all wallpaper
was arsenic-laced.
Arsenic poisoning has a variety of symptoms
including headaches, cold sweats, and fainting.
There was an 1880 report of a woman who had
“fainting fits almost daily,” until she
was moved to another room in her home that
wasn’t furnished with arsenic-tainted wallpaper
– where she recovered a few weeks later.
In addition, arsenic, along with lead, mercury
and other such toxic substances, were commonly
found in makeup during the Victorian era.
(see: Why Lead is Bad for Humans) Lead was
also a common ingredient in hair dyes and
was frequently found in wine (along with arsenic
and copper).
Together, these toxins contributed to more
wealthy Victorians suffering from seizures
(and, theoretically, swooning) when compared
with their poorer neighbors who couldn’t
afford such luxuries.
All that said, it is highly likely that some
(or even the majority) of this swooning was
put on.
You see, besides potential side effects from
the fad of extreme tight lacing of corsets
or other such things, for a time, swooning
at the least hint of a shock also became expected
and downright ladylike.
(This also made it a great literary device
in stories.)
Women, particularly of high station, were
expected to act the role of a delicate flower,
while men were expected to be hard as nails.
(see: In Which Teddy Roosevelt Makes Men Everywhere
Feel a Little Less Manly)
Swooning was simply one method of a woman
showing her delicate nature in the form of
an extreme emotional reaction to a particular
event.
Today, simply gasping might be the best social-cue
equivalent.
Similarly, people rarely laugh when by themselves,
even when finding something incredibly humorous.
In fact, contrary to popular belief, most
laughter is not associated with humor, but
rather stems from non-humor related social
interactions.
This was noted in a study covering over 2,000
cases of naturally occurring laughter, almost
none of which stemmed from jokes or other
such humor devices.
Most cases were simple, short “ha ha’s”
during otherwise normal conversations.
These short laughs almost never interrupted
speech, but rather occurred during breaks,
providing social cues to those around.
So in the 19th century, swooning was just
another form of accepted social cue for ladies
to have in their toolbox, whether they literally
were fainting or just, more likely in most
cases, making a show of it.
Beyond this, the ladies also had another potential
incentive for swooning.
You see, at the time, well-to-do women often
had something called a “fainting room”.
This was a room for the woman to recover from
a fainting spell and other forms of so-called
hysteria.
Besides just getting to relax in piece on
a comfortable fainting chair, there was another
benefit.
A doctor or midwife could be called to attend
to a woman who was suffering from some form
of hysteria, which included symptoms of swooning,
among other things.
And by “attend to”, we mean give vigorous
pelvic massage, whether manually with their
hands or using a water massager, if attending
to the woman in their offices or other location
that had one.
This went on until the lady in question was
relieved, curing her of her hysteria.
This was also a boon to doctors at the time
who otherwise tended to be avoided by the
general public unless absolutely necessary.
Treating female hysteria, though, was something
women who had the money often needed done
regularly and were more than happy to pay.
However, this was very time consuming and
could require some amount of physical exertion
for the midwife or doctor in question, particularly
if they had to attend to multiple ladies in
the same day in this way, with “doctors
lamented that treating hysterics taxed their
physical endurance.”
In this case, the husband could potentially
also be called in to help.
Later, this practice, and the cramped hands
of physicians throughout Europe and North
America, led to the invention of the vibrator
for quickly relieving such “hysteria,”
saving the physicians significant time and
effort.
In the early 20th century as houses wired
up with electricity became more and more common,
the vibrator for this use became something
of a common household item for those who could
afford one.
With it, you didn’t even need to necessarily
call the doctor to relieve hysteria.